In the previous video we used the listing
method to write the set of first three natural
numbers all we did was write the list of
elements with these curly brackets each
separated by a comma there is another way in which we can
represent the set we just saw
That is the first three natural numbers It is written as
the set of all  The
method is far
simpler and clearer than writing it this way but
you will soon see this is a very
powerful way to write a set I will
explain its benefits in a bit but for now let's just understand what this
actually means we will understand it  In
detail part by part the brackets have the same
meaning it says that what is written inside it
is a set now the next part is important we have a
variable here we have
called it x but you can name it anything so
in our example this can  b red as all x the
colon means true that this is the first new thing we learn here
a colon means true that so this
part is red as
set off
all  Two conditions separated by
comma this one and this one The first
condition is simple it says x i Lesson 4 We have this
condition since we have been asked for just the
first three natural numbers but this condition
is not enough as less than fo can mean any
decimal  Numbers and Negative Numbers Less Than Four and
Ts Pro Silly Why We Have the Second
Condition This Is Red S x Belongs to n
Where n Means All
Natural Numbers It
Means  Allowed it is
red as set of all x true that x is
less than
4 and
Is pleasing to the eye We again try
to represent the first three natural
numbers 1 to and three in this method we just
draw a circle and write the elements inside it
so here we draw a circle and write the
elements 1 to and three inside it this  Is
Called The Venn Diagram The essence is
represented with in a
circle All the methods have their pros and cons
No method is good or bad It all depends on the
set we are looking at We will understand each
of the methods with examples in the coming
videos